Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History. Today's topic is one I've been looking forward to ever since we came up with the idea for this podcast. It is weird wars. Our favourite obscure, little known, colourful or just downright strange wars. It's probably worthwhile saying in the beginning. Of course every war involves an awful lot of suffering, so we're not making light of that. Well, no more than is tasteful, anyway.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告播客、抢先收听系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。今天的主题是我自从萌生制作这个播客的想法以来就一直非常期待的。这就是离奇战争。我们最喜欢的那些鲜为人知、默默无闻、多姿多彩或简直荒诞不经的战争。在开始之前，可能值得说明一下。当然，每一场战争都伴随着大量的苦难，所以我们并不是在拿这个开玩笑。好吧，至少没有开到不合时宜的程度。
My ever-tasteful guest is Tom Holland. Hello, Tom. Guest? I'm not your guest, Dominic. I'm your co-presenter. Stop trying to elbow me off. Let's have a war about it. The pod war of 2021. I hoped. I've been saving that up for weeks.
我那位永远得体的嘉宾是托姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）。你好，托姆。嘉宾？我不是你的嘉宾，多米尼克。我是你的联合主持人。别想把我挤开。让我们为此打一仗吧。2021年播客大战。我希望如此。我为此憋了好几个星期了。
I'm thinking, when can I, if I distract him with some just sort of blather, then I can sneak that in and he won't notice. And then once it's said, it is said. I noticed. I noticed. Well, as the host, Dominic, perhaps you'd like to spell out what the format is. So we're going to choose five wars each. And with all due respect to the casualties, we're going to choose five wars each and uh with all due respect to the casualties
我在想，我什么时候能——如果我用一些废话转移他的注意力，然后我就能悄悄把这个塞进去，他就不会注意到了。而且一旦说出口，那就覆水难收了。我注意到了。我注意到了。好吧，作为主持人的多米尼克，也许你想阐述一下这期的赛制？所以我们每个人要挑选五场战争。而且出于对死伤者的所有尊重，我们每个人要挑选五场战争，呃，出于对死伤者的所有尊重……
we're going to discuss them and um what's strange about them and um then and that's it really it's very simple yeah yeah maybe we can have a public vote on who has the best one yeah exactly since we're not taking since we haven't taken questions we'll obviously um welcome feedback and people can choose their favorites um yeah and i'm sure that we think we've most misrepresented all the one that we've missed out i'm sure listeners will have their own their own so they will indeed and i suppose it's worth saying as well you know we're doing this from you know comfortable prosperous britain uh and and these wars seem weird to us but of course they don't seem weird to the people in their countries involved. So to some extent they reflect our ignorance and solipsism, I suppose.
我们要讨论它们，呃，它们离奇在哪里，呃，然后——就这样，非常简单。对，对，也许我们可以搞一个公众投票，看看谁选的最好？对，没毛病。既然我们不接受——既然我们还没有收集提问，我们显然会，呃，欢迎大家的反馈，大家可以挑选自己最喜欢的——对，而且我敢肯定，我们会把所有的都代表得面目全非，或者漏掉某些战争，我确信听众们会有他们自己的看法。他们确实会有。而且我想这也值得一提，你知道，我们是在一个舒适繁荣的英国录制这个节目……而这些战争在我们看来很离奇，但对于身处其中的国家的人民来说，它们当然一点也不离奇。所以在某种程度上，我想这也反映了我们的无知和唯我论。
Yes. But with that caveat, why don't you go first? Give us one of your wars. Okay, I'm going to kick off with the oldest war I've got on my list, which dates from 590 BC. And it's the First Sacred War. And it actually takes us back to a theme we touched on in the previous podcast which is Delphi and it it was it was fought by a league of Greek cities who were anxious that a city called Kira which was the port that people would land when they
是的。但有了这个前提，你为什么不先来？给我们讲讲你的第一场战争。好的，我要以我名单上最古老的一场战争开局，它的历史可以追溯到公元前590年。这就是第一次圣战（First Sacred War）。它实际上把我们带回了我们在上一期播客中触及的一个主题，那就是德尔斐（Delphi），这是一场由一个希腊城市同盟发起的战争，他们感到焦虑，因为有一个叫基拉（Kira）的城市——人们在……
wanted to go to Delphi that Kira was becoming too dominant and essentially wanted to absorb Delphi into its own kind of framework of power. So a league of cities, which included Sicyon, which was a city on the north of the Peloponnese, kind of directly opposite Kira, and Athens, several other cities as well, got together and they were told to do this they said by apollo and apollo basically said not only capture kira but nuke it nuke all the lands around it make them uninhabitable um i don't want anyone ever living there again and so what um what this league does is they lay siege to kira and they cut off the water supply so that everyone in Kira starts to um to die of thirst and then they take a poisonous plant called Hellebor and they put it in the
想要去德尔斐时登陆的港口就是基拉——变得过于强势，实质上是想把德尔斐吞并到它自己的权力框架中。因此，一个城市同盟，其中包括西锡安（Sicyon，伯罗奔尼撒北部的一个城市，位置差不多正对基拉）和雅典，还有其他几个城市，联合在了一起，他们被告知要这样做，他们说是阿波罗（Apollo）下的指示，阿波罗基本上说：不仅要攻占基拉，还要把它炸平，把基拉周围所有的土地都炸成不毛之地，我不想再让任何人住在那儿。所以，这个同盟所做的事情就是，他们围攻基拉，切断了水源，导致基拉的每个人都开始渴死，然后他们把一种叫铁筷子（Hellebor）的有毒植物放进……
water supply and the water goes back in and everyone in Kira drinks harsh and in some way we're not quite sure it the lands all around kira are indeed left devastated because um we have the record of pausanias who is a geographer writing around 150 ad so centuries after this war and he says that the plains around kira um are completely barren um people don't plant trees there the land is still under a curse um the anger of apollo still marks it um and again we we talked in the the last podcast about how the priests of apollo were really the only professional priests and that's because of the sacred war it's essentially because this league get together and say that delphi is you know it it has to be a kind of independent temple complex it cannot come under the influence of any one city um but i i
水源里，水流了回去，基拉的每个人都喝了下去，通过某种我们不太确定的方式，基拉周围的土地确实成了一片废墟。因为……我们有保萨尼亚斯（Pausanias）的记录，他是一位地理学家，生活在大约公元前150年左右，也就是这场战争之后的几个世纪，他说基拉周围的平原完全是荒芜的……人们不在那里种树，这片土地依然受到诅咒，阿波罗的愤怒仍然留下了痕迹……同样，我们在上一期播客中谈到过，阿波罗的祭司实际上是唯一的职业祭司，这是因为那场圣战。本质上是因为这个同盟联合起来说，德尔斐必须是一个独立的神庙综合体，它不能受到任何单一城市的影响。但我……
choose this because i think it's um you know it's it's kind of the first example really of uh of of using plants to poison people it's kind of hint of chemical warfare there chemical water um so there's no sense that the greeks had that this was bad form that they thought it was crafty yes i mean it's it's clearly remembered because it was seen as being terrible um and it required the sanction of um of apollo and then it kind of interesting context I think for the sense that something quite sinister had happened is that um suppose well there are various accounts about how this came about I think this is kind of a hint of legend there but one of the accounts says that um the person who comes up with this idea is a guy called Nebros who is a follower of Asclepius who is the god of healing um and one of his descendants supposedly is Hippocrates
选择这个是因为我认为这可以说是……呃，利用植物毒害人类的第一个例子，其中带有一点化学战的暗示，化学水……所以希腊人并没有觉得这种做法有失体面，他们认为这很狡猾。是的，我的意思是，它显然被人们铭记了，因为它被视为极其残暴，这需要得到阿波罗的批准。然后，我认为它作为一个有趣的背景，说明曾经发生过非常邪恶的事情，那就是……嗯，关于这件事是如何发生的有各种不同的说法，我认为这其中有一点传说的暗示，但其中一种说法称……
okay and Hippocrates of course the guy that you know you if you become a doctor you swear you won't do people any harm and there is a thesis that this the Hippocratic oath is is a kind of an attempt to make amends for his ancestor, what his ancestor did in the first sacred war. So anyway, so that's my first choice. But you said it's the first sacred war. There are other sacred wars. Yes, there are further sacred wars, but they're not quite as much to talk about.
想出这个主意的人是一个叫内布罗斯（Nebros）的家伙，他是阿斯克勒庇俄斯（Asclepius，治愈之神）的追随者，据说他的后代之一就是希波克拉底（Hippocrates）。
Okay, fair enough. All right, I'm going to go in really strong with my first one. So my first one is The War of Canudos. Have you ever read a book called The War at the End of the World by Mario Vargas Llosa? I have. So, yes, in that case you'll know that it's about a war in Brazil in 1896 to 7.
好吧，希波克拉底当然就是那个……如果你成为一名医生，你就会发誓不伤害任何人的那个人。有一种论点认为，这个《希波克拉底誓词》其实是一种试图弥补他的祖先在第一次圣战中所作所为的举动。不管怎样，这就是我的第一选择。但你刚才说这是第一次圣战。还有其他的圣战吗？是的，还有后续的圣战，但没那么多好聊的。
So basically what happened was the Brazilians, Brazil was this colossal plantation, effectively, for several hundred years. And then at the end of the 1880s, the Brazilian emperor abolished slavery, Dom Pedro II, but then the military kicked him out and they wanted him to go. And for the next 10 years, Brazil was very unstable, very sort of tense a sort of tense conflicted place and in this fragmented landscape this sort of prophet figure called antonio concilero antonio the counselor he comes along and he's basically says let's set up in in bayern in this sort of back country very poor
好吧，有道理。好，我的第一个选择要放大招了。所以我的第一个选择是卡努杜斯之战（The War of Canudos）。你读过马里奥·巴尔加斯·略萨（Mario Vargas Llosa）写的《世界末日之战》（The War at the End of the World）这本书吗？读过。所以，是的，如果是这样的话，你就会知道那是关于1896到1897年在巴西发生的一场战争。
big slave ex-slave population a lot of mixed race people as well. He says, let's set up this sort of sacred community at a place called Canudos and we'll wait there for the coming of the late, the medieval Portuguese king, Sebastien. Sebastien will come and he will bring the sort of the new Jerusalem and better times. So all these people i mean thousands of people go to live at this place and the brazilian military who are all
所以基本上发生的事情是，巴西，巴西在长达几百年的时间里，实际上是一个庞大的种植园。然后在1880年代末，巴西皇帝佩德罗二世（Dom Pedro II）废除了奴隶制，但随后军方把他赶下台，他们想让他离开。在接下来的10年里，巴西非常不稳定，局势非常紧张，是一个充满紧张冲突的地方。在这个破碎的景观中，出现了一个类似先知的人物，名叫安东尼奥·孔瑟略（Antonio Conseheiro，安东尼奥顾问），他基本上说：让我们在巴伊亚（Bahia）的这个偏远地区建立据点，那里非常贫困……
um secularists and freemasonry is very strong in brazil so that freemasonry and sort of enlightened thinking and stuff they say these people are backward they're monarchists they're going to bring the country down we must crush them and extirpate them and they send troops and there's multiple attacks on canudos um and eventually the military wins they destroy the the settlements they kill most of the people they kill about 25 000 people and it's this extraordinary conflict so on the one side you've got the forces of kind of progress and liberty and order and modernity who are effectively, in the novel and in the sense of the war, they're the kind of bad guys. And then the other, you have the dispossessed bandits, ex-prostitutes, ex-slaves who tend to be black who are in this city,
有着大量前奴隶人口，还有很多混血儿。他说：让我们在卡努杜斯（Canudos）这个地方建立一个神圣的社区，我们在那里等待已故的中世纪葡萄牙国王塞巴斯蒂安（Sebastien）的降临。塞巴斯蒂安会来，他会带来新的耶路撒冷和美好的时代。所以所有这些人——成千上万的人去那个地方生活——而巴西军方，他们全都是……
and they end up all being killed. So it's kind of a sad, it's a strange, very strange, but sad story. Is it famous in South America? Do you know? I think it's famous in Brazil. Right. And I think, you know, Brazilian, nobody in the West, in Western Europe really knows any Brazilian history, I suppose, unless they're Portuguese. We certainly don't know it in England. I mean, you know, it's a black hole, I guess. And its strangeness, I think, comes from the fact that, you know,
世俗主义者，而且共济会在巴西非常强大，所以共济会、某种启蒙思想等等，他们说这些人是落后的，他们是保皇派，他们会毁了国家，我们必须粉碎他们并根除他们。他们派出了军队，对卡努杜斯发动了多次进攻……最终军队获胜了，他们摧毁了定居点，杀死了大部分人，杀死了大约25,000人。这是一场非同寻常的冲突：一方面，你拥有代表进步、自由、秩序和现代性的力量，在小说中以及从战争的意义上讲，他们实际上是某种“坏人”。而另一方面，你拥有流离失所的强盗、前妓女、前奴隶——往往是黑人——他们住在这个城市里……
we have no real reference points from a sort of Anglo-Saxon perspective. But also because it's almost like the Waco siege writ large. Remember the Waco siege in the 90s? It's got a slight element of that about it, but because it's rooted in this sort of world of slavery and of intense racism and of sort of this fanaticism about progress. So the Brazilian army just think
最后他们都被杀光了。所以这是一个悲伤的、非常奇怪但又悲伤的故事。它在南美洲有名吗？你知道吗？我认为它在巴西很有名。对。而且我想，你知道，在西方，在西欧，没有人真正了解任何巴西历史，除非他们是葡萄牙人。我们在英国当然不了解。我的意思是，这是一个黑洞，我猜。它的离奇之处，我认为来自于这样一个事实，即……
we need to sort of completely destroy these people because they're backward. It makes you think the whole magical realist tradition in South American fiction, but actually the real you think the whole magical realist tradition in South American fiction. Yeah. The realist. It is quite realist. Yeah.
从盎格鲁-撒克逊的角度来看，我们没有真正的参照点。而且也因为它几乎就像是韦科惨案（Waco siege）的放大版。还记得90年代的韦科惨案吗？它带有一点那样的色彩，但因为它根植于这种奴隶制、极端种族主义以及对进步的狂热的世界中。所以巴西军队只是认为……
I mean, strange things really are going on. Well, I'm going to come back to South America with a later war because I think their wars are so little known here and often they're incredibly violent
我们需要彻底消灭这些人，因为他们很落后。这让你想起南美小说中的整个魔幻现实主义传统，但实际上，你觉得南美小说中的整个魔幻现实主义传统其实是现实的。是的。现实主义。它确实很现实。是的。
and bloody. Okay. Well, my next choice also has a prophet, but it's a female prophet and she features in um the umayyad berber war of the 690s to 702 ad wow that is that is an issue this is a great this is a this is this is an astonishing war um so it's taking place during the arab conquest of um the uh coast. So they conquered Egypt,
我的意思是，奇怪的事情真的在发生。好吧，我稍后会用另一场战争回到南美洲，因为我认为他们的战争在这里鲜为人知，而且往往极其暴力……
they sweep westwards, they come to the Byzantine province of Africa, so it ruled from Constantinople, including the great city of Carthage. It falls and the Arab commander, his troops are now looking westwards towards the Straits of Gibraltar and ultimately Spain but to do that they have to get past the Berbers who are notoriously tough opponents they you know they'd oppose the Byzantines they'd oppose the Visigoths they'd oppose the Romans they'd oppose the Carthaginians they're very very tough opponents and the Arabs are overconfident and they they go sweeping in and they come up against the Berbers who are led by a queen called Diyah. But she is better known by the Arab word for prophetess, Al-Kahina.
并且血腥。好吧，我的下一个选择也有一个先知，但这是一个女先知，她出现在公元690年代到702年的倭马亚柏柏尔战争（Umayyad Berber war）中。哇，那真的是……这是一个重大事件。这是一场伟大的、令人震惊的战争。所以它发生在阿拉伯人征服……海岸期间。他们征服了埃及……
And she is supposed to have had the gift of being able to speak to birds. So she was kind of well-informed. So, you know, they were her scouts. She was meant to have um murdered her husband on her wedding night um and according to ibn kaldun the great um arab historian writing in the middle ages um she's meant to have been jewish not not um uh descended from um children of israel but she had adopted the Jewish faith. Interesting. Supposedly. Although there are other traditions
他们向西横扫，来到了拜占庭帝国的阿非利加行省（province of Africa），也就是由君士坦丁堡统治的地区，包括伟大的城市迦太基（Carthage）。它沦陷了，阿拉伯指挥官的军队现在正向西眺望直布罗陀海峡（Straits of Gibraltar），最终是西班牙，但要做到这一点，他们必须击败柏柏尔人，这些柏柏尔人是出了名的顽强对手，你知道的，他们曾对抗过拜占庭人、西哥特人、罗马人、迦太基人，他们是非常非常顽强的对手。而阿拉伯人过于自信，他们长驱直入，遇到了由一位名叫迪亚（Diyah）的女王领导的柏柏尔人。但她更常被称为阿拉伯语中的“女先知”——卡希纳（Al-Kahina）。
that say that she was a Christian or that she was a pagan. Basically, we don't know very much about her, but almost everything we do know about her is fantastical. And it's clear that she did, she defeats the Arabs in a great battle beside a river
据传说，她拥有与鸟类对话的天赋。所以她消息非常灵通……你知道的，鸟类就是她的侦察兵。据说她曾在新婚之夜谋杀了自己的丈夫……根据中世纪著名的阿拉伯历史学家伊本·赫勒敦（Ibn Khaldun）的记载，据说她是犹太人——不是以色列人的后裔，但她皈依了犹太教。有趣。据说如此。尽管也有其他传统……
in 696. And the Arabs retreat and they lick their wounds. And Dia is anxious that they're going to come back. So what she does supposedly is to try and create a corner sanitaire by kind of destroying everything so that the Arabs won't have anything to forage or live off. But this just alienates her subjects. And so when the Arabs come back this time, she loses. She gets pursued into the mountains and she gets killed in battle. And she's supposed, before she dies, to tell her sons, go and become Muslim. And she's supposed to say to all the Berbers, become Muslim.
说她是基督徒，或者她是异教徒。基本上，我们对她知之甚少，但我们所知道的几乎所有事情都是神话般的。很显然，她在696年河畔的一场大战中击败了阿拉伯人……阿拉伯人撤退并舔舐伤口。迪亚担心他们会卷土重来。所以据传说，她试图通过摧毁一切来创建一个隔离区（cordon sanitaire），这样阿拉伯人就没有任何东西可以觅食或赖以生存了。但这只会疏远她的臣民。因此，当阿拉伯人这次卷土重来时，她战败了。她被追赶到山区，并在战斗中丧生。据说在她死前，她告诉自己的儿子们：去皈依伊斯兰教吧。她还对所有的柏柏尔人说：皈依伊斯兰教吧。
Right. How convenient that that's in the Arab tradition. She's kind of, I suppose, the North African Boudicca. She's the great warrior queen who's fighting the imperialists. And so she's put to, and the fact that she's supposedly Jewish as well, you know, made her a subject of great interest in the 19th century. She was used by the French as a kind of emblem of resistance to islam and she was used by um people in algeria as an emblem of resistance against the french she's she's quite a kind
对。这在阿拉伯传统中出现得可真巧。我想，她有点像是北非的布狄卡（Boudicca）。她是那个与帝国主义者战斗的伟大女战士女王。因此，她被塑造成……而且她据称也是犹太人这一事实，在19世纪引起了极大的兴趣。她曾被法国人用作抵抗伊斯兰教的象征，也被阿尔及利亚人民用作抵抗法国的象征。她是一个相当具有可塑性和潜力的象征。
of malleable and potent symbol so this is in modern day algeria right this is yes modern day algeria why did she win if it where did she win initially because the arabs had carried all before them hadn't they i I mean, they were unstoppable. I think the Berber's just very, very tough. Very tough. And maybe they've been underestimated by the... Yeah, and also the Arabs are going along the north coast, where there are cities, where it's much easier to water your horses,
所以这是在今天的阿尔及利亚，对吧？是的，这就是今天的阿尔及利亚。她为什么能赢？最初她在哪里赢了？因为阿拉伯人此前势如破竹，不是吗？我的意思是，他们势不可挡。我想柏柏尔人只是非常非常顽强。非常顽强。也许他们被……低估了？是的，而且阿拉伯人沿着北部海岸前进，那里有城市，给马匹饮水要容易得多……
get supplies, and they're defeated in more hostile terrain. Yeah, never go into the interior. That's the lesson. Never go into. Yeah, never go into the interior. That's the lesson. Never go into the interior. Never go into the interior. But I choose her because I think that prophetesses who are kept informed of their enemies' movements by birds, I don't think there are enough of them in the historical record.
获取补给也更容易，而他们是在更恶劣的地形中被打败的。是的，永远不要进入内陆。这就是教训。永远不要进入。是的，永远不要进入内陆。这就是教训。永远不要进入内陆。永远不要进入内陆。但我选择她是因为我认为，那些随时通过鸟类获知敌人动向的女先知，在历史记录中还不够多。
No, that's right. So I give you Al-Kahina. Okay. Well, since you've done an African one, especially one where people go into the interior i'm going to choose a very strange um african war in which people go into the interior so this is the british expedition to abyssinia 1867 68 so if you've for the listeners who've read the flashman books um this is flashman in Ethiopia, if you remember that. So this is a war that basically begins with an unanswered letter.
不，确实如此。所以这就是我介绍的卡希纳。好吧，既然你讲了一个非洲的故事，特别是那种人们深入内陆的故事，我要选一场非常奇怪的……非洲战争，人们在这场战争中也深入了内陆。这就是英国1867至1868年的阿比西尼亚远征（British expedition to Abyssinia）。所以，对于读过《弗莱什曼历险记》（Flashman books）的听众来说，这就是埃塞俄比亚版的弗莱什曼，如果你还记得的话。所以这是一场基本上由一封未回复的信件引发的战争。
So you have Abyssinia, Ethiopia, and their king is called Tewodros II. People called him Theodore in Britain. And he's a sort of modernizer. Everyone said he was this great romantic figure, a kind of Robin Hood of a king who wanted to break the power of the old kind of land-owning elite and sort of drag his country towards the 19th century and build things and all this business.
所以当时有阿比西尼亚（Abyssinia，即埃塞俄比亚），他们的国王叫特沃德罗斯二世（Tewodros II）。英国人叫他西奥多（Theodore）。他是一个改革派。每个人都说他是一个伟大的浪漫人物，一个国王中的罗宾汉，想要打破旧地主精英阶层的权力，把他的国家拉向19世纪，大兴土木，诸如此类。
And he provoked a lot of rebellions, and he wanted military assistance from Europe. So he writes these letters to, I think, Russia, France and Britain. And he writes to Queen Victoria and says, can you please send me some military aid? And Queen Victoria ignored his, was told by the Foreign Office, don't write back, just, you know, ignore him, he'll go away. He's the Emperor of Abyssinia, you need to give him no thought at all.
他引发了许多叛乱，他希望得到来自欧洲的军事援助。所以他写信给……我想是俄国、法国和英国。他写信给维多利亚女王，说：能不能请你给我提供一些军事援助？维多利亚女王忽视了他的信——外交部告诉她：不要回信，就……忽略他，他会自讨没趣而离开的。他是阿比西尼亚皇帝，你根本不需要搭理他。
And, you know, she's probably got other things on her mind. So two years went by, he was outraged that he didn't get a reply from Queen Victoria. Did the Russians and French reply? No, they didn't reply at all. I mean, that was the sort of, yeah, I mean, he didn't get any help from anybody. People treated him very badly. But he was particularly outraged about Queen Victoria. And in revenge revenge he started capturing missionaries and um sort of British traders and people wandering through and locking them up as hostages until he got a reply from Queen Victoria yeah fair enough so the British had an expedition to to crush him and this expedition came was the army it came from Indiaia uh read by sir robert napier who was a leading sort of general in india
而且，你知道的，她可能还有其他更重要的事情要操心。于是两年过去了，他因没有收到维多利亚女王的回复而勃然大怒。俄国人和法国人回信了吗？不，他们根本没有回信。我的意思是，那就是……是的，我的意思是，他没有得到任何人的帮助。人们对他的态度非常恶劣。但他对维多利亚女王格外愤怒。为了报复……报复，他开始扣押传教士、英国商人和四处游荡的人，把他们关起来作为人质，直到他收到维多利亚女王的回复为止。嗯，好吧。所以英国人发动了一场远征来粉碎他，这场远征的军队来自印度……由罗伯特·纳皮尔（Sir Robert Napier）率领，他是印度的主要将领之一……
and they have this colossal military expedition they land on the red sea they have to take all kinds of engineers and things to basically get them across 400 miles into the the sort of heart of ethiopia they don't really know where they're going um you know it's this sort of real sort of leave in the dark and they go all this way i mean they go 400 miles um to odros he retreats to his sort of mountain citadel a place called magdala with the missionaries with the sort of prisoners um and he's determined to hold out. And so they siege and they defeat his army and the British break in. And ironically, he shoots himself with a duelling pistol that was a present from Queen Victoria.
他们拥有庞大的军事远征队，在红海登陆，他们不得不带上各种工程师，基本上是为了让他们穿越400英里的路程，进入埃塞俄比亚的心脏地带。他们其实并不知道自己要去哪里……你知道的，这真是一种在黑暗中摸索的真实写照，他们走了这么远——我的意思是，他们走了400英里——特沃德罗斯退守到他的山地城堡，一个叫马格达拉（Magdala）的地方，带着传教士和囚犯……他决心坚守到底。于是他们围攻并击败了他的军队，英国人攻了进去。具有讽刺意味的是，他用一把维多利亚女王赠送的决斗手枪自杀了。
And do we loot all kinds of stuff and bring it back to the British Museum, that kind of thing? Exactly. And then we sort of came home again and said, you know, in future, when we don't reply to your letters, you know, behave yourself and don't take it so badly. So in the Flashman books, Flashman sort of presents it as a, we were talking about historical fiction in one of the previous podcasts,
然后我们是不是掠夺了各种各样东西并把它带回了大英博物馆，诸如此类的事情？没错。然后我们又回家了，说：你知道的，以后当我们不回你的信时，放尊重点，别那么大惊小怪。所以在《弗莱什曼历险记》中，弗莱什曼某种程度上把它呈现为——我们在之前的某期播客中谈到过历史小说——《弗莱什曼》这本书实际上把它描绘成一个相当悲伤的故事，西奥多只是想要一封回信。
and the Flashman book actually presents it as quite a sad story that Theodore just wanted to reply to his letter. well i'm completely on his side the british lost so the abyssinians lost hundreds of people i think the british lost two we lost two men in the whole expedition because we had the gatling gun and they did not precisely we had all this technology and you know just fighting people with um swords and spears and muskets. Okay, well, time for one more from me, and then we'll have the break. And Dominic, I chose this one especially for you, because I think that you're going to pick up on why I've chosen it.
嗯，我完全站在他这一边。英国人赢了，而阿比西尼亚人死了几百人。我想英国人只死了两个人。我们在整场远征中只死了两个人，因为我们有加特林机枪，而他们没有。确切地说，我们拥有所有这些科技，你知道的，只是在和拿着剑、长矛和滑膛枪的人作战。好吧，我还有一个名额，然后我们就中场休息。多米尼克，我特意为你挑选了这一场，因为我想你能看出我为什么选择它。
And it's the German-Hungarian War of 955. Wow, is that the Battle of the... The Battle of the River Lech. Yes, Battle of the River Lech. And the two contestants on this, have um the uh the saxon kings saxon kings are highly mobile heavy cavalry um they're in possession of the spear of power the spear that supposedly pierced the uh the side of christ on the cross and is possessed of a terrifying potency power that's of power. That's amazing.
这就是公元955年的德意志-匈牙利战争（German-Hungarian War of 955）。哇，那是……勒希河战役（Battle of the River Lech）吗？是的，勒希河战役。这场战争的两个对手拥有……呃，萨克森国王们拥有高度机动性的重骑兵……他们拥有权力的长矛（spear of power），那根据传说曾刺穿十字架上基督肋旁的矛，拥有可怕的威力。权力的力量。这太神奇了。
And they look back to the example of Charlemagne and ultimately of the Roman Empire. But there is no empire. That has gone. So no emperors. And on the other side, we have the Hungarians who are highly mobile. People who've settled on the Carpathian plain with their horses. They're able to launch raids against Christian Europe.
他们回顾查理曼大帝（Charlemagne）的榜样，并最终追溯到罗马帝国的榜样。但帝国已经不复存在了。它已经消逝了。所以没有皇帝。而在另一边，我们有匈牙利人，他们高度机动。这群人在喀尔巴阡平原（Carpathian plain）带着马匹定居下来。他们能够对基督教欧洲发动突袭。
Christians find them impossible to hold off. Completely terrifying. The Hungarians are supposed to drink blood. They're seen as demonic children of the devil, portents of the apocalypse. So the whole backdrop to this is kind of lit up by a sense of the clash of good and evil, of the satanic and the angelic, and the feeling that patterns are being written on the flux of time, all of which provides the background for what is the ultimate Hungarian invasion, where they come not with horses but with siege engines as well and this time they're trying to conquer and their target is augsburg and they bring huge battering ram siege engines um and the message goes to uh otto who is up in the north in saxony please come to our rescue and in the meanwhile the citizens of Augsburg have to hold off.
基督徒发现根本无法抵挡他们。完全令人恐惧。匈牙利人被认为会喝血，他们被视为魔鬼的恶魔化身、末日的预兆。所以这一切的背景都被一种善恶交织、撒旦与天使对抗的氛围所点燃，这种感觉仿佛是在时间之流上书写着命运的图腾。所有这些都为最终的匈牙利入侵提供了背景，他们这次来不带马匹，还带了攻城器械，这一次他们试图征服，他们的目标是奥格斯堡（Augsburg），他们带来了巨大的攻城冲车。消息传到了位于北方萨克森的奥托（Otto）：请来拯救我们。与此同时，奥格斯堡的市民们必须坚守阵地。
And they are led in the siege by the Bishop of Augsburg, Ulrich, a guy with a great long flowing white beard who rides around on his horse on the battlements. Oh, I can see where this is going. The mighty hordes of the East who have flooded out. And at one point, the gates are smashed by the battering ram. And Ulrich stands there holding up his cross to stop the Hungarian hordes from coming in. And people come to the rescue and they're able to hold up the gate.
在围城战中领导他们的是奥格斯堡的主教乌尔里希（Ulrich），一个留着长长飘逸白胡子的家伙，他骑着马在城墙上巡视。哦，我看出这要走向何方了。东方汹涌而至的强大部落。有那么一会儿，城门被冲车撞破了。乌尔里希站在那里，高举十字架，阻止匈牙利部落涌入。人们赶来救援，他们成功顶住了城门。
And just when it seems the city is about to fall, people in Axburg hear the battle horns and they look up to the hill and they're arriving the cavalry of the heavy cavalry led by um led by Otto who charges down the hill shatters the uh the Hungarian hordes they're trampled down and that evening um amid the the cries and howls of dying across the plains beyond Augsburg, Otto is hailed by his troops as Imperator, as Emperor. And six years later in Rome, he is crowned as Emperor and it is the return of the Imperator. So I give you that because there are clearly echoes there of Return of the King. And I know you're because there are clearly echoes there of Return of the King.
就在这座城市似乎即将陷落的时候，奥格斯堡的人们听到了战号声，他们抬头望向山丘，由奥托率领的重骑兵正赶来支援，他从山坡上冲下来，粉碎了匈牙利部落，他们被践踏在地。那天傍晚……在奥格斯堡之外平原上垂死之人的哭喊和哀号声中，奥托被他的部队欢呼为“统帅”（Imperator），即皇帝。六年后的罗马，他被加冕为皇帝，“统帅”归来。我给你讲这个是因为这里显然有《王者归来》（Return of the King）的回声。我知道你是……因为这里显然有《王者归来》的回声。
And I know you're a Tolkien fan. When this podcast goes out, I think they should put under it the Lord of the Rings soundtrack for your monologue. And people can listen to it on a loop. Yes. Okay. So on that perhaps slightly histrionic tone,
我知道你是个托尔金（Tolkien）迷。当这期播客播出时，我想他们应该在你的独白下面配上《指环王》（Lord of the Rings）的配乐。人们可以单曲循环听它。好的。所以在这种可能略带矫揉造作的基调下……
let's go for a break. When we come back, we've got five more weird wars for you. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix
我们休息一下吧。当我们回来时，我们将为你带来另外五场离奇的战争。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的……
of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched
娱乐新闻、评论、八卦花絮。在我们的问答环节，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了……
our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to this episode of The Rest Is History. We're doing our top 10 weird wars. Five from me, five from Dominic. Dominic, your turn, your third choice. Well, Tom, you took us out on a note of high melodrama there with your Siege of Augsburg. So I shall come back with some low comedy.
我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到本期《历史的余烬》。我们正在盘点十大离奇战争。我选五场，多米尼克选五场。多米尼克，轮到你了，你的第三个选择。好吧，托姆，你刚才用奥格斯堡围城战那种高强度的情节把我们带向了高潮。那我就用一些低俗喜剧来收尾吧。
It is, of course, the War of Jenkins's Ear. Everybody's famous ear-based war. There aren't enough, are there? No, there aren't. So this is a war that went from 1739 to 1748, although I think most of the fighting ended a little bit earlier. And if people know anything about it, I mean, most people know practically nothing about 18th century wars, do they? But if people know anything about it, they'll know that there was a fellow calledbert jenkins who was a welsh merchant whose ship was captured by the spanish um in the caribbean and jenkins was sort of trading they suspected him of smuggling and
这当然就是詹金斯的耳朵之战（War of Jenkins's Ear）。这是世人皆知的“以耳朵为基础”的战争。这样的战争还不够多，对吧？确实不多。所以这是一场从1739年持续到1748年的战争，尽管我认为大部分战斗结束得稍早一些。如果人们对它有所了解——我的意思是，大多数人对18世纪的战争实际上几乎一无所知，对吧？但如果人们了解一点，他们就会知道有一个叫罗伯特·詹金斯（Robert Jenkins）的家伙，他是一个威尔士商人，他的船在加勒比海被西班牙人扣押了……而詹金斯当时在进行某种贸易，西班牙人怀疑他在走私……
trading illegally so they cut his ear off so this happened actually in 1731 which is eight years before the war happened so jenkins comes back home and uh the story goes that he exhibited his ear to a to the house of commons so he had a pickle to carry around a jar and he's supposedly i'm sure it was horrid well it turns out this story is totally untrue actually uh he didn't He did nothing of the sort. There are cartoons done at the time showing him, showing his ear to Sir Robert Walpole, who was prime minister, and Walpole looking away because he doesn't want to look at it. He wants to eye up some girls instead. This is what's happening in the cartoons. And this was because the sort of opposition to Walpole wanted war with Spain.
进行非法贸易，所以他们割下了他的耳朵。这实际上发生在1731年，也就是战争爆发的八年前。所以詹金斯回到家后……故事是这样的，他在下议院展示了他的耳朵……他随身带着一个泡在罐子里的耳朵。据说是这样，我敢肯定那一定很可怕。嗯，事实证明这个故事完全是假的，实际上……他根本没有这么做。当时的漫画描绘了他向首相罗伯特·沃波尔爵士（Sir Robert Walpole）展示自己的耳朵，而沃波尔则把头扭开，因为他不想看。他宁愿去打量几个姑娘。这就是漫画中发生的事情。这是因为反对沃波尔的势力想要对西班牙开战。
They wanted – the Spanish were not letting the British trade with their colonies. They weren't letting our ships in to sell them goods, particularly in a sort of, there was a lot of tension along the coast of North America where the British had just started up a colony in Georgia, which was next to the Spanish colony in Florida. The British wanted to get into Florida. The Spanish weren't having it. So people wanted Walpole to go to war.
他们想要——西班牙人不让英国人与他们的殖民地进行贸易。他们不让我们的船只进去售卖货物，特别是在北美海岸一带，那里局势高度紧张，英国人刚刚在佐治亚（Georgia）建立了一个殖民地，紧挨着西班牙在佛罗里达（Florida）的殖民地。英国人想进入佛罗里达。西班牙人不让。所以人们想让沃波尔开战。
And they used Jenkins' ear as an example of what they saw as these sort of Spanish depredations. They said, you know, this fellow's had his ear cut off. You're not doing anything about it. Do you have a question, Tom? I do. I was wondering, is this when Walpole says, let sleeping dogs lie?
他们以詹金斯的耳朵为例，作为西班牙人他们眼中这种掠夺行为的证据。他们说：瞧，这家伙的耳朵都被割下来了。你们却什么都不做。托姆，你有什么问题吗？我有。我想知道，这就是沃波尔说“别去惹麻烦”（let sleeping dogs lie）的时候吗？
I don't know. That's a good question. Maybe it is. That's a very good question. Maybe it is. i hope it is well there are you'll find out there are some interesting things we've got from the war of jenkins here so finally we go to war in 1739 walpole's kind of at the end of his time and he says fine he's always tried to stay out of wars but he says fine have your war we fight this war
我不知道。这是个好问题。也许是吧。这是一个非常好的问题。也许是的。我希望是。好吧，你会发现，我们从詹金斯的耳朵之战中得到了某些有趣的东西。所以最终我们在1739年开战了，沃波尔的任期也接近尾声，他说：好吧——他一直极力避免战争，但他说：好吧，那就如你们所愿开战吧。我们与西班牙人开战……
with the spanish and basically actually the war jenkins is a bit pathetic because it ends up it's a bit of a draw nothing happens it gets subsumed into the war of the austrian succession which i have to confess i know virtually nothing about um however the war the jenkins is it does give us a couple of things so one of the great sort of um high points for the british is we capture a place called portobello in panama and we get two things from that. One is Portobello Road, which comes from Notting Hill. There's an area of Edinburgh called Portobello as well. And we get Royal Britannia.
说实话，詹金斯的耳朵之战有点可悲，因为它最终有点像是不分胜负，什么也没发生。它被并入了奥地利王位继承战争（War of the Austrian Succession）中，我必须承认我对这场战争几乎一无所知……然而，詹金斯的耳朵之战确实给我们留下了一些东西。所以对英国人来说的一个伟大“高光时刻”是，我们攻占了巴拿马的一个地方叫波托贝洛（Portobello），我们从中得到了两样东西。一个是波托贝洛路（Portobello Road），它来自诺丁 HILL。爱丁堡也有一个叫波托贝洛的地方。另一个是我们得到了《不列颠尼亚万岁》（Rule, Britannia!）。
So Royal Britannia was written after the capture of Portobello to sort of celebrate our great victories in the Caribbean. So the last line of the problem is we could all wave ears. Yeah. Well, I mean, I do that. I mean, no one would complain about that. That would unite the country in a shared sense. Yeah.
所以《不列颠尼亚万岁》是在攻占波托贝洛之后写的，用来庆祝我们在加勒比海的伟大胜利。所以问题的最后一句是：我们都可以挥舞耳朵。是的。嗯，我的意思是，我会这么做。我的意思是，没有人会抱怨这一点。这将以一种共同的情感团结整个国家。是的。
Instead of people going with sort of EU flags as they do now, everybody should take giant ears. Just wave an ear. Yeah. That would surely be seen as anti-Spanish, though. Wouldn't it be seen as Hispanophobic now? I'm sure the Spanish wouldn't mind. Yeah, they'd surely be seen as anti-Spanish, though. Wouldn't it be seen as Hispanophobic now? I'm sure the Spanish wouldn't mind. Yeah, they'd probably go over it.
与其像现在这样人们挥舞着欧盟旗帜，不如人人都拿着巨大的耳朵。就挥舞一只耳朵。是的。那肯定会被视为反西班牙的吧？现在难道不会被视为仇视西班牙吗？我确信西班牙人不会介意。是的，他们肯定会被视为反西班牙的吧？现在难道不会被视为仇视西班牙吗？我确信西班牙人不会介意。是的，他们大概会一笑置之。
An opportunity to wave large ears in the air. I mean, I'm sure they wouldn't object. Right, well, my fourth one also involves trading wars over vast distances. And it's the Dutch-Portuguese War, which went from 1602 to 1663. And the reason I've chosen this is because I think that actually this is the First World War. Wow, that's a big claim. And the reason it's the First World War, I mean, I suppose you've got the Mongol conquest, haven't you? I mean, that's ranging from Japan up to wherever, Hungary.
这是一个在空中挥舞大耳朵的好机会。我的意思是，我确信他们不会反对。好吧，我的第四个选择也涉及跨越巨大距离的贸易战。这就是荷兰-葡萄牙战争（Dutch-Portuguese War），从1602年一直持续到1663年。我之所以选择这个，是因为我认为这实际上才是第一次世界大战。哇，这是一个很大的宣称。之所以说它是第一次世界大战——我的意思是，我想你可能会提到蒙古征服，对吧？我的意思是，那从日本一直延伸到匈牙利或其他什么地方。
Yeah, but not all at the same time, surely. Yeah, and it's all on one continent. Whereas the thing about the Dutch-Portuguese war is that it is properly global. Okay, yeah. So Portugal has, over the course of the late 15th, 16th century, has carved out this empire, which would include Brazil, Cape of Good Hope,
是的，但肯定不是同时发生的，对吧？是的，而且全都在一个大陆上。而荷兰-葡萄牙战争的特点在于它是真正全球化的。好吧，是的。所以葡萄牙在15世纪末到16世纪的进程中，开辟了这个帝国，其中包括巴西、好望角……
Angola, Goa in India, various kind of Macau and so on, and various places controlling the spice trade in the Pacific. And you've got the Dutch as the kind of the coming traders. It's basically, as with the British conquest of India, it's basically kind of companies who are running this war rather than the Netherlands itself. So it's the Dutch East and West India companies who are pushing it. And you get wars that span South America, Africa, India, the Pacific.
安哥拉、印度的果阿（Goa）、澳门等等，以及控制太平洋香料贸易的各种地方。而荷兰人则是新晋的商人。基本上，正如英国征服印度一样，这场战争主要是由公司在运营，而不是荷兰本身。所以是荷兰东印度公司和西印度公司在推动它。你看到这场战争跨越了南美洲、非洲、印度和太平洋。
And the Dutch don't manage to take Brazil. They don't manage to take Angola, but they do, with momentous consequences, seize the Cape of Good Hope. So that's essentially, you know, lots are going to come from that. And although the Portuguese keep hold of Goa and Macau, the Dutch basically kind of elbow them out of the way to seize control of the specific spice trade. So that's Indonesia?
荷兰人没能攻占巴西。他们没能攻占安哥拉，但他们以具有重大历史意义的结果，夺取了好望角。所以这本质上是……你知道的，很多事情都将由此产生。尽管葡萄牙人保住了果阿和澳门，但荷兰人基本上把他们挤开了，夺取了特定香料贸易的控制权。所以那是印度尼西亚？
The Dutch East Indies? Yeah, so Indonesia, Jakarta, Batavia and so on. And it's a war over spice, but it is, I think properly, the First World War. So that's why I've chosen it. and is that where um
荷属东印度群岛？是的，所以是印度尼西亚、雅加达、巴达维亚（Batavia）等等。这是一场关于香料的战争，但我认为它确实是第一次世界大战。这就是我选择它的原因。苏里南（Suriname）是从那里来的吗？
suriname comes from because suriname was a dutch colony am i right in south america yes and and um also they the dutch build the fort at gore which uh provides the backdrop um for the test match in sri lanka so that's another reason for choosing it. So that's a nice war, because those are two people who you don't imagine going to war with each other, you know, Holland and Portugal. A sort of, you know, perennial World Cup quarterfinalists. Well, except that Portugal at this time is ruled by the Spanish king. So obviously there's a bit of beef between the Spanish and the Dutch,
因为苏里南曾是荷兰的殖民地，我在南美洲没记错吧？是的，而且……荷兰人还在加勒（Galle）建造了城堡，这为斯里兰卡的板球测试赛提供了背景……所以这也是我选择它的另一个原因。所以这是一场很好的战争，因为那是两个你想象不到会互相开战的国家，你知道的，荷兰和葡萄牙。一种……你知道的，世界杯淘汰赛里常见的常青树。好吧，除了此时的葡萄牙是由西班牙国王统治的。所以很显然，西班牙人和荷兰人之间有点过节，这可以追溯到过去。但实际上葡萄牙人觉得他们没有得到西班牙人的全力支持。所以这是葡萄牙决定再次独立的巨大推力因素。
so that is going back. But actually the Portuguese feel that they haven't been properly backed by the Spanish. So that's a massive contributory factor in the Portuguese deciding to go independent again. Right. Interesting. Because I was going to say, well, to the Spanish. And the Portuguese, so the Portuguese lost this war. This was a Dutch win.
对。有趣。因为我正想说，嗯，对于西班牙人来说。而葡萄牙人——所以葡萄牙人输掉了这场战争。这是一场荷兰的胜利。
Yeah, basically. Yeah. Okay. But then, but you know who the real winners are? The British? The English? Yes. How do I guess? But you know who the real winners are? The British? The English? Yes. Because basically the Portuguese and the Dutch are left so exhausted
是的，基本上。好吧。但是，你知道真正的赢家是谁吗？英国人？英格兰人？是的。我怎么猜到的？但你知道真正的赢家是谁吗？英国人？英格兰人？是的。因为基本上葡萄牙人和荷兰人被折腾得筋疲力尽……
that it's then easy pickings for the English to move in. So that's how the English get hold of, you know, the Dutch rule Gaul and Sri Lanka for a while, and then it's not long before the British are muscling in. So as per normal, we are the bad guys. Perfidious Albion. Yeah. Okay.
以至于英格兰人随后可以轻而易举地介入并摘桃子。所以这就是英格兰如何控制了……你知道的，荷兰人统治了果阿和斯里兰卡一段时间，然后没多久英国人就大举挤进去了。所以像往常一样，我们就是坏人。背信弃义的阿尔比恩（Perfidious Albion）。是的。好吧。
Jolly good. I've got two left, haven't I? So I shall go with probably the more bizarre of my two remaining choices. This is the War of the Triple Alliance, which is also – I mean, that doesn't give anything away, does it? It could be anywhere. But it's also known as the Paraguayan War. So this is actually a terrible war.
太棒了。我还有两个没讲，对吧？所以我将选择我剩下的两个选择中可能更离奇的一个。这就是三国同盟战争（War of the Triple Alliance），它也——我的意思是，这什么也没透露，对吧？它可以在任何地方。但它也被称为巴拉圭战争（Paraguyan War）。所以这其实是一场可怕的战争。
This is an unbelievably bloody war, which begins for very sort of obscure reasons. So Paraguay is generally a very strange place, completely landlocked in the middle of South America. It was basically a sort of Spanish administrative division that broke away when the Spanish lost South America. And it was run for a while by a man called Dr. Francia, who was a disciple of Rousseau. And he tried to run Paraguay. He tried to make it an idealized Rousseau-style society. So it was completely isolationist. He had complete control. He was very anti-clerical. He was very keen on prostitution as one of the sort of key industries
这是一场难以置信的血腥战争，其起因非常隐晦。所以巴拉圭通常是一个非常奇怪的地方，完全深居南美洲腹地，四周都是陆地。它基本上是西班牙失去南美洲时分裂出来的一个西班牙行政区划。它曾由一个叫弗兰西亚博士（Dr. Francia）的人统治一段时间，他是卢梭（Rousseau）的信徒。他试图统治巴拉圭。他试图把它变成一个理想化的卢梭式社会。所以它是完全孤立主义的。他拥有绝对的控制权。他非常反神职人员。他非常热衷于将卖淫作为某种核心产业之一……
of paraguay so again it sounds like a kind of magical realist it does exactly so paraguay is this weird introverted place and um and basically paraguay also kind of starts the war which you would think is a foolish thing to do if you're going to take on argentina and brazil so there is a conspiracy theory actually interestingly going back to your last war there is a conspiracy theory. Actually, interestingly, going back to your last war, there's a conspiracy theory that actually the British planned this war. We're so bad, aren't we? But it turns out to be totally untrue. It's very deeply rooted in South America, but academics think it's totally untrue.
关于巴拉圭的战争，所以听起来确实有点像魔幻现实主义。确实如此，巴拉圭是一个非常诡异、内向的国家，而且基本上也是巴拉圭挑起了这场战争。如果你要同时对抗阿根廷和巴西，这显然是个愚蠢的做法。事实上，有一个阴谋论——有意思的是，回到你们刚才讨论的上一场战争，也有一个阴谋论。事实上，有趣的是，回到你们上一场战争，有一个阴谋论认为其实是英国人策划了这场战争。我们真是太坏了，对吧？但事实证明这完全是无稽之谈。这个说法在南美洲根深蒂固，但学者们认为这纯属无稽之谈。
The British, for their own perverse reasons, wanted the Paraguayans defeated, which we didn't. So when the Paraguay decide they're going to fight Argentina and Brazil simultaneously, and they reckon they can handle handle it and it turns out that they can't so the war lasts six years it basically goes on in the 1860s the same time as the american civil war and it is colossally bloody so about half a million people die in total the paraguayans are totally defeated um and they lost. So get this. Historical estimates about the number of people who died
英国人出于其变态的理由，希望巴拉圭人战败，而我们其实并不希望如此。所以当巴拉圭人决定同时向阿根廷和巴西宣战时，他们自认为能够应付得来，结果却发现根本应付不了。因此这场战争持续了六年，基本上发生在1860年代，与美国内战同期。这场战争极其血腥，总共大约有五十万人丧生。巴拉圭人彻底战败，并且输了。所以你听着，历史估计的死亡人数
from Paraguay's population range between about 60% and 90%. Goodness me. So basically everybody, or a colossal proportion of people are killed. At the end, there are about four or five times as many women in Paraguay as there are men. And historians and sociologists think that this has sort of completely affected paraguay's development ever since and paraguay is utterly brutalized by its neighbors it's occupied basically most the vast majority of the men are killed and ever since paraguay has remained this very sort of strange, introverted, quite isolationist regime. So that's
占巴拉圭总人口的比例在大约60%到90%之间。天哪。基本上所有人，或者说绝大多数人都被杀害了。到战争结束时，巴拉圭女性的人数大约是男性的四到五倍。历史学家和社会学家认为，这彻底影响了巴拉圭自那以后的发展。巴拉圭遭到其邻国的极度摧残，国家被占领，绝大多数男性被杀害。自那以后，巴拉圭一直保持着这种非常奇特、内向且相当孤立的政权。所以这就是
why it was the sort of destination of choice for Nazi war criminals at the end of World War II, because you could be sure that no one's going to come after you in Paraguay. The only person I know who's been to Paraguay is Alan Wicker. In Wickers, there's a brilliant edition of Wickers World where he goes to Paraguay. But anyway, yeah, the Paraguayan War. Nobody knows about it. And it was colossally, it was horrible. That sounds horrible. Okay, well, I'm going to give you a war now where nobody dies,
为什么它在二战结束后成为了纳粹战犯的首选流亡目的地，因为你可以确信在巴拉圭没有人会来追捕你。我认识的唯一去过巴拉圭的人是艾伦·威克尔（Alan Whicker）。在《威克尔的世界》里有一集非常精彩，他去了巴拉圭。不过话说回来，是的，巴拉圭战争。根本没人知道它。而且它极其惨烈，太可怕了。听起来真可怕。好吧，现在我要给你们讲一场没有人员伤亡的战争，
or at least no humans die. That's a cheery war. It's the Emu War of 1932. Are you familiar with the Emu? Is it Rod Hull? It's not Emu War of 1932. Are you familiar with the Emu? Is it Rod Hull? It's not Rod Hull. No, it's in a way even a lot funnier than Rod Hull. So this is about, it's rather kind of Roman.
或者至少没有人类伤亡。这是一场轻松愉快的战争，1932年的鸸鹋战争。你们熟悉鸸鹋吗？是罗德·赫尔（Rod Hull）吗？不是鸸鹋战争，是1932年的。你们熟悉鸸鹋吗？是罗德·赫尔吗？不是罗德·赫尔。不，某种程度上它比罗德·赫尔还要滑稽得多。所以这事是关于——它有点像是古罗马式的。
Roman soldiers would come back and be given plots of land. And rather similarly, after the First World War, Australian troops coming back to Australia were given plots of land in arable territory in Western Australia. And they set up their farms there. And then their lands get invaded by a task force of 20,000 emus. Wow, a task force. And the emus kind of devastate the land. And so all these soldiers start saying, well, we need to take them out.
罗马士兵退役后会分到土地。与此类似，第一次世界大战后，回到澳大利亚的澳大利亚士兵也在西澳大利亚的耕地地区分到了土地。他们在那里建立了自己的农场。然后，他们的土地遭到了一支由2万只鸸鹋组成的“特遣队”的入侵。哇，一支特遣队。鸸鹋基本上摧毁了土地，所以所有这些士兵开始说，嗯，我们需要消灭它们。
And of course, they're all very good with machine guns and things. Yeah. Kind of armed to the teeth. And the Royal Australia Artillery see an opportunity to kind of have a bit of practice so they can use the emus as target practice. And so they go in to take on the emus. And there was all kinds of jingoistic footage, which you can see. And it's kind of, yeah, boy's going in.
当然，他们都非常擅长使用机枪之类的武器。是的。简直武装到了牙齿。澳大利亚皇家炮兵看到了一个进行实战演习的好机会，他们可以把鸸鹋当作靶子来练习。于是他们出动去对付鸸鹋。当时有各种各样的沙文主义影像资料，你们都可以看到。那感觉就像是，是的，小伙子们要上了。
Look at these emus running at 40 miles per hour. These are tough enemy. And it turns out actually they are incredibly tough enemy because they just run. And then they kind of come up in the rear and take out all the take out all that take out all the crops and um the uh the commander uh ends up comparing them to zulus he says that you know they they just kind of melt away and then when you think that uh you've got them on the run, suddenly they attack you from the side. And he says that they kind of, you know, when facing machine guns, they have the invulnerability of tanks.
看看这些以每小时40英里速度奔跑的鸸鹋。这是个强悍的敌人。事实证明，它们确实是个极其强悍的敌人，因为它们只管逃跑。然后它们从后方包抄，摧毁了所有的——摧毁了所有的庄稼。而且指挥官最后竟然把它们比作祖鲁人，他说，你知道的，它们就像那样消散开去，而当你以为你已经把它们逼得溃逃时，它们突然从侧翼向你发起进攻。他还说，面对机枪时，它们拥有坦克般的刀枪不入之身。
And the whole thing is a kind of a parody of colonial wars, really. Yeah. the kind of the mismatch between heavily armed european troops and the way in which kind of repeatedly they find it difficult to um essentially kind of enforce their will um and and the emus basically get away with it and yeah the emus kind of win yeah i mean they it's it's it's basically it's i think pretty much the only war that dinosaurs have won since the Mesozoic. So hold on, a lot of these Australians, are they veterans of the First World War? Yeah. God, so they could beat the Germans, but they couldn't beat the Emus. Well, I guess they're kind of used to being in trenches where you know where the enemy are whereas the emus yeah you know they can run at 40 miles an hour
整件事其实就是对殖民地战争的一种讽刺。是的。全副武装的欧洲军队与他们多次发现自己难以基本上强行贯彻其意志的方式之间的错位，而鸸鹋基本上全身而退了，是的，鸸鹋算是赢了。我的意思是，这基本上是——我认为这几乎是自中生代以来恐龙赢得的唯一一场战争。等等，这些澳大利亚人很多都是一战老兵吗？是的。天哪，所以他们能打败德国人，却打败不了鸸鹋？好吧，我想他们习惯了那种你知道敌人具体在哪里的战壕战，而鸸鹋呢，你知道的，它们能以每小时40英里的速度奔跑，
so it is a kind of place yes it is a kind of metaphor for vietnam or something isn't it it is and um and of course you know looking ahead you've got um you've got singapore lots of singapore you've got the french indochina you've got vietnam um yeah so there's iran as a kind of, yes, as a metaphor for the Western way of war and its inadequacy, it's kind of perfect. And if I were a magical realist novelist, I was ready for this. Yeah. Surely some, there's an Australian Booker Prize winner in this, isn't there? You thought so, yes. All right. Well, my final war is a bit less jolly. It's a very bloody war, probably the bloodiest one we've done. It's the Russian Civil War. So this is a colossal war that often we know nothing about. We sort of assume the Russian Revolution happened and then you have the Soviet Union and it's sort of inevitable. But of course it wasn't inevitable, not least because the Allies hoped to strangle Bolshevism at birth.
所以这确实是个地方——是的，这有点像是越战之类的隐喻，不是吗？确实是。当然，展望未来，你还有——你有新加坡，很多新加坡，你还有法属印度支那，你还有越南。是的，所以伊朗作为一个——是的，作为西方战争方式及其无能的一种隐喻，它简直完美。如果我是一个魔幻现实主义小说家，我已经准备好写这个了。是的。肯定有哪个澳大利亚布克奖得主会写这个题材，对吧？你这么认为，是的。好吧，我的最后一场战争就没那么轻松了。这是一场非常血腥的战争，可能是我们讲过的最血腥的一场。这就是俄国内战。所以这是一场巨大的战争，我们往往对此一无所知。我们想当然地认为俄国革命发生了，然后就有了苏联，这一切都是不可避免的。但当然这并不是不可避免的，尤其是因为盟军希望把布尔什维克扼杀在摇篮里。
So we were landing small amounts of troops at Archangel and Murmansk and whatnot. But also because it looks like a war from a video game, from a sort of computer strategy game, or if you're playing Risk or something. So you have these colossal armies kind of wandering across these massive expanses of territory. The Bolsheviks are surrounded. There are white Russian armies on all sides. And often it looks as though the Bolsheviks are going to lose because the whites control colossal areas of Siberia and stuff. There are very strange combatants.
所以我们在阿尔汉格尔斯克和摩尔曼斯克等地登陆了少量的军队。但这也是因为这场战争看起来像是一个电子游戏，来自某种电脑策略游戏，或者如果你在玩《帝国风险》之类的话。所以你会看到这些庞大的军队在广袤的领土上游荡。布尔什维克被包围了。四面八方都是白卫军。而且看起来布尔什维克往往会输，因为白军控制了西伯利亚等地的广阔区域。这里面有非常奇怪的参战方。
So the Baltic states are involved. Poland are involved, Ukraine. The Allies are involved, but also, of course, the Germans are involved because at the end of the war, the Germans are still in the game. There are people like the Mountainous Republic of the Northern Caucasus, so all these countries that don't exist anymore that are involved too. And my favorite competence, the ones that I find most intriguing, are a group of people, there are about 50,000 of them,
波罗的海国家卷入了，波兰卷入了，乌克兰也卷入了。盟军卷入了，当然，德国人也卷入了，因为在战争结束时，德国人依然在局中。还有诸如北高加索山地共和国之类的人群，所有这些已经不复存在的国家也参与其中。而我最喜欢的参战方，我最感兴趣的群体，是一群大约有5万人的武装力量，
called the Czech Legion. So you might wonder why the Czech Legion are in Russia. They're prisoners of war. They're Austro-Hungarian prisoners of war that have been held in camps in Russia. And basically when czarism fails, they decide that they are going to go, they want to rejoin the war. They want to get back to what becomes Czechoslovakia. But they can't go west because of the Germans and the wars. They decide they're going to go east. They'll go all the way to the Pacific by train. Then they'll go through the US, across the Atlantic, and they'll get back that way.
被称为捷克斯洛伐克军团。所以你可能会好奇为什么捷克斯洛伐克军团会在俄罗斯。他们是战俘。他们是被关押在俄罗斯营地的奥匈帝国战俘。基本上，当沙皇专制崩溃时，他们决定要离开，他们想重新加入战争。他们想回到日后成为捷克斯洛伐克的故土。但由于德国人和战事，他们无法向西走。他们决定向东走。他们要坐火车一路去太平洋。然后通过美国，横渡大西洋，以此方式返回。
Like a sort of gap year gone horribly wrong. But basically, on the way, they get distracted and they get drawn into the war. They seize control of the entire Trans-Siberian Railway. And there were these sort of trains of Czechs for months, crossing Russia, capturing towns, intervening in the war. And at one point, you know, they're the biggest threat to the Bolsheviks. So that doesn't appear in Dr. Zhivago, does it?
就像是一次彻底搞砸的间隔年。但基本上，在路上，他们分心了，被卷入了战争。他们夺取了整条西伯利亚大铁路的控制权。有几个月的时间，俄罗斯各地到处都是这种捷克人的列车，他们攻占城镇，干预战争。在某个阶段，你知道的，他们是布尔什维克最大的威胁。所以这并没有出现在《日瓦戈医生》里，对吧？
No, it doesn't, but it should. I mean, it's such a great story. They appear a bit in a book called People's History of Love by James Meek, a novel, and the Czechs are in that. But the Czechs are really never discussed in sort of western um sort of histories of communism the soviet union because they sort of they did get back they went all the way they they messed around in the war for a bit and then they kind of lost interest um and and went off to the pacific um and went through america and they did get back i mean it's
不，并没有，但它本应该出现。我的意思是，这是一个如此棒的故事。他们在詹姆斯·米克（James Meek）的小说《爱的人民历史》（People's History of Love）中稍微出现过，捷克人就在那本书里。但捷克人从未在西方关于共产主义和苏联的历史中被讨论过，因为他们最终确实回去了，他们走了一路，他们在战争中瞎混了一会儿，然后就失去了兴趣，动身前往太平洋，通过美国回去了，他们确实回去了。我的意思是，这真是
an amazing story they traveled thousands of miles in these armoured trains. And, of course, the Bolsheviks won. The Bolsheviks won the war because they controlled the industrial centres and they controlled Moscow, but also because they were the only people that were really selling the Russian peasantry a positive message. So the sort of the whites, I mean, they're very much kind of skull and crossbones kind of characters. They're very anti-Semitic, and they just have this pure sort of the whites i mean they're very much kind of skull and crossbones kind of characters they're very anti-semitic and they just have this pure sort of negative they want
一个惊人的故事，他们乘着这些装甲列车行进了数千英里。当然，布尔什维克赢了。布尔什维克赢得了战争，因为他们控制了工业中心和莫斯科，还因为他们是唯一真正向俄国农民兜售积极信息的力量。所以白军——我的意思是，他们非常像是骷髅旗那种角色。他们极度反犹，而且他们只有这种纯粹的——白军，我的意思是，他们非常像是骷髅旗那种角色。他们极度反犹，而且他们只有这种纯粹的负面诉求，他们想要
to bring back feudalism and reactionary kind of um uh sort of reactionary world of czarist russia and not surprisingly the rush the ordinary russians don't really fancy that but you know it could have gone it could have gone either way. And it's just such a massive, confused, you know, it feels like a board game gone wrong in which millions of people die. I mean, you know, millions upon millions of people die. And as you said at the beginning, that is the key thing to bear in mind
带回封建主义和沙皇俄国那种反动落后的世界。毫不奇怪，普通的俄国人并不太看得上这些，但你知道的，这场战争原本可能走向任何结局。这只是一场巨大而混乱的冲突，感觉就像是一场玩砸了的棋盘游戏，数以百万计的人在其中丧生。我的意思是，你知道的，千百万人丧生。正如你一开始所说的那样，这是需要记住的关键一点，
is that everything we've discussed, apart from the emu war, even some emus die, is, yeah, yeah terrible although the interesting thing though tom i thought we'd um discuss this right at the end is there are some historians who argue that wars are good things so for example margaret mcmillan in her wreath lectures in a book about war you know she sort of says people not war but war is often a great force for progress lots of inventions um but also society you know human society often progresses by kind of leaps and bounds that are driven by wars
那就是我们讨论的一切，除了鸸鹋战争——甚至连一些鸸鹋也死了，是啊，是啊，都很糟糕。不过，有趣的是，汤姆，我想我们可以在最后讨论一下这个问题：有些历史学家认为战争是件好事。例如，玛格丽特·麦克米兰（Margaret MacMillan）在她的里思讲座（Reith Lectures）和关于战争的书中，你知道的，她某种程度上说，人们不是渴望战争，但战争往往是进步的巨大推动力，带来了许多发明，而且社会——人类社会往往是通过由战争驱动的突飞猛进向前发展的。
but then again dominic war what is it good for oh yeah yeah absolutely nothing discuss maybe maybe we'll have maybe we'll have a podcast on whether war is good for anything um some later time i think it's probably easy to say war is good for anything some later time. I think it's probably easy to say it's good for something if you're in your seminar room. If you're in a trench, maybe it feels a bit... Or if you're a mighty conqueror. Yeah, drinking from your adversary's skull.
但话又说回来，多米尼克，战争究竟有什么用？哦，对，完全没有用。讨论一下吧，也许——也许我们以后会做一期播客，讨论战争到底有没有用。我想，如果你坐在研讨室里，说战争对某些事有好处可能很容易。如果你身处战壕，感觉可能会有点……或者如果你是一个伟大的征服者。是的，用敌人的头骨喝酒。
Well, that's a charming note on which to end. We will be back on Monday when we will be discussing the 90s. And that's the 1990s. We will see you then. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. We've got another podcast that we'd love you to try as well. It's obsessed with history too, but just six years of history, albeit a pretty important six years. It's called We Have Ways of Making You Talk, and it's all about the Second World War. My brother, James Holland, presents the show with comedian and avid historian Al Murray. Here's a taster.
好吧，这是一个迷人的结束语。我们将在周一回归，届时我们将讨论90年代。也就是1990年代。到时见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。我们还有另一档播客想推荐给你尝试。它也对历史着迷，但只专注于短短六年的历史，尽管那是相当重要的六年。它叫作《我们有办法让你开口》（We Have Ways of Making You Talk），专门讲第二次世界大战。我的兄弟詹姆斯·霍兰德（James Holland）与喜剧演员兼狂热历史爱好者阿尔·默里（Al Murray）共同主持这个节目。以下是一个试听片段。
We have ways of making you talk wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, buddy, look out. Hey, buddy, look out. Which is, of course, American English for Achtung, Achtung. How are you this morning, Jim? Yeah, no, I'm not too bad. How about you? Oh, all right.
无论你在哪里收听播客，我们都有办法让你开口。嘿，伙计，当心。嘿，伙计，当心。这当然是美式英语里的“注意，注意”（Achtung, Achtung）。吉姆，你今天早上过得怎么样？是的，不坏。你呢？哦，挺好的。
Yeah, you know. How did you pass your time over the weekend? no, I'm not too bad. How about you? Oh, all right, yeah, you know. How did you pass your time over the weekend? How did I pass my time over the weekend? Building a diorama of Bastogne. Oh, yeah, I've got to say, that is looking sehr toll, I have to say. Well, it's, yeah, oh, and you've been on Duolingo learning German, haven't you? Have I? How can you tell? Ich kenne nicht, aber du hast sehr gute Skills mit das Deutsch.
对，你知道的。你周末是怎么过的？不坏。你呢？哦，挺好的，对，你知道的。你周末是怎么过的？我是怎么过周末的？搭建了一个巴斯托涅的立体模型。哦，是的，我必须说，这看起来“非常棒”（sehr toll），我得这么说。好吧，是的，哦，你一直在用多邻国有滋有味地学德语，对吧？我吗？你怎么看出来的？我不知道（Ich kenne nicht），但是你的德语技能非常好（hast sehr gute Skills mit das Deutsch）。
I do know how to say the ducks are eating the flies, which is obviously very useful. Die Enten frissen sie fliegen. Yeah, we need to work on that accent. Die Enten frissen sie fliegen. There you go.
我的确知道怎么说“鸭子在吃苍蝇”，这显然非常有用。“Die Enten frissen sie fliegen”。是的，我们需要练练那个口音。“Die Enten frissen sie fliegen”。就是这样。
Goering really was rubbish, wasn wasn't he and isn't it amazing that had had he been operating for you know had he be operating in the soviet union you know he just would not have survived till 1945 no not a chance and it's odd that hitler doesn't quite have the same ruthlessness as stalin i don't think well yeah, yeah, but that's Hitler's sort of tendency towards indecision, isn't it, as much as anything else? He'd rather they're all fighting each other and that saves him having to make a decision. Stalin is all about siloing the power in himself and using people to do his bidding
戈林真是个废物，不是吗？而且难道不是很神奇吗，如果他当时是在——你知道的，如果他是在苏联运作的话，你知道的，他根本不可能活到1945年。是的，绝对没可能。很奇怪的是，希特勒似乎没有斯大林那种程度的冷酷无情，我是这么觉得的。好吧，对，但那是希特勒倾向于犹豫不决的性格，对吧，很大程度上也是如此？他宁愿让他们互相争斗，这样就省得他自己做决定了。斯大林则是要把权力高度集中在自己手中，并利用别人来执行他的命令，
until he decides they're no use to him anymore. And when they're no use to him anymore, they tend to end up purged. There's such a difference in style, in actual fact. Yeah. And there is that, the end of the war hit, they're saying, oh, Stalin had it right. It's a thing we've talked about before.
直到他认为这些人对他没有利用价值了为止。当他们对他没有利用价值时，往往就会被清洗掉。风格上的差异真是太大了，事实上。是的。而且还有那种情况，战争快结束时，希特勒说，哦，斯大林做对了。这是我们以前讨论过的一个话题。
Yeah. Stalin had it right. I wish I'd been as ruthless as him. But yeah, you're absolutely right. Going would have lasted five minutes in the Soviet Union. I mean, he's so shit. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha. thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。斯大林做对了。我真希望自己能像他一样冷酷无情。不过是的，你绝对没说错。戈林在苏联撑不过五分钟。我的意思是，他太烂了。哈哈哈哈哈哈。感谢收听《历史的余烬》，获取独家加更剧集、提前抢先收听以及无广告收听。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。